You're sitting in here writing fanfiction. Don't make me tell
the truth. He's so pressed right now. I've literally never seen
Dude, people come to Asenold and they're like, "You your mom
and your dad is happy that you're that he's dead now that he
doesn't have to live with you." And Asen Gold's like, "Water
off a duck's back, [__] I don't feel you're a piece
of [__] for saying that, but I don't feel anything
from it." I didn't believe that he was dating Emmy until he started
responding to some of this stuff.
cuz Denims posted this this afternoon. Okay, which is just she
posted this and Asminold seethed about this. Okay.
Okay. Breaking messages between Emir and Asminold have been leaked.
What's going on with ICE executing American citizens? Don't worry,
kitten. Okay. Yay.
Okay.
It's like a meme. Asmin Gold literally went live and he's like,
"You want to photoshop messages between me and Emiru? Well, maybe
I'll do something to you." It's like, bro, it's like not a photo.
It's a stupid meme that everybody could tell. It's not like she's
trying to pass this off as if she really as if she really had
leaking leaked messages of you, bro. Are you serious?
Are you serious?
All right. Anyway, we'll look at the Asold response to this real
quick.
Know why Twitter lets this go on? I really don't. I mean, you've
got to in Oh, hold on. No way,
dude. Bro, it's crazy.
And really, this just makes me I heard that. We all heard him
say that, right? Like he implied that somehow Twitter should
be protecting Emiru. Bro, I just I have to give it up to Msk
one more time. Okay, Msk.
Msk hitting that and nothing changes with him. Okay, he's still
a total psycho. Asmin Gold hits that one time and he's immediately
like, I think we should protect all women on Twitter
100 just a complete 180 from every stance he's ever had in the
past. Okay. Just a total 180 immediately.
>> Talked about a little bit yesterday.
>> It's just again people people that want to, you know,
they want to attack somebody so they can uh, you know, use their
platform for politics. That's generally what it is, right? I
mean, I I just, you know, my my advice to anybody has that happen,
right? is like, "Bro, you you let somebody else tell you what
to do." Like, I mean, is it really your stream or is it theirs?
And so, I never let somebody go and tell people tell me what
to do or say anything, right? I mean, like, uh, I I've had times
where like people have given me advice and I've been like, "Okay,
maybe I'll take this seriously." But like, uh, anytime that I
have people that go and attack me and say bullit about me, um,
I just immediately don't even listen to them, right? Like that's
it. Chat holding you. Yeah. Cuz like this is the way I look at
it, right? is that in a normal um like as a as a content creator,
right, is that like I like being a content creator and I like
doing what I'm doing is because I one reason is that I don't
really have a boss, you know? I have like parameters like I can't
say the for example, right? And yeah, that takes out like there's
a lot of opportunities and things that I would say if I could
say the but I can't. And so yeah, it nothing's perfect, but overall
what I'm saying is that um you know there are other things that
I would want to you know like do at a normal job, but I'd never
be able to do that. You can. Not yet. No, of course not. I know
it's a big tragedy. Sorry, I was reading something. Well, you
could you could say it soft day. I feel like
a soft day you I think I think we're at a place on Twitch where
Asmin Gold would be fine saying the soft day. In fact, I would
support Asmin Gold testing that out. >> I don't know why
Twitter lets this go on. I really don't. I mean, you've got to
in my opinion, I think people that are saying, >> okay,
but that's not a threat. It's not a threat to or something. It's
like uh this person
should unalive themselves. That's what it is. >> This kind
of stuff. You You've got to go and ban them for that, right?
You do. And uh we're somebody just please please protect Emmy
widows. Yeah, exactly. Like I I don't even I don't see how this
is even a controversy. Like obviously you should ban anybody
who's like you know subtly like uh you know trying to advocate
for violence or try to do that. >> Bro, I'm you see asold's
found a loophole. As long as you advocate for state violence
then it's fine. Okay. That's legal. When I want the cops to kill
people that's legal. Okay. That's legal. That's okay. That's
awesome. that's based when you when you guys talk about it. That's
that's gay. Okay. That's so gay. >> And so, uh, yeah, that's
really it. Sponsors. No, I mean, and also like and here's another
thing is that you've got to keep in mind that like AT&T is
a really big company and they don't want to work with me and
they don't want to work with Hassan. So, it's not necessarily
that these companies uh don't like my politics. Now, maybe they'd
be more uh you know allowing of lefting left-wing politics. I
think that's true. Generally, I think that is true and I don't
like that. But to say that like you know either of the why because
they don't want to be involved. They don't want to have to like
it it you're buying internet. You don't want to have internet
get political. What the [__] does that have to do
with it? So the people that are obsessed with putting their pol
or putting politics in everything are actually not obsessed with
putting politics in everything. They are obsessed with putting
their politics in everything and that's what the goal is. So
they want to put and make it to where they want to create a world
where you cannot escape their influence. You can't watch a stream,
you can't watch a movie, you can't see a video game, you can't
play a video, you can't see a TV show because everything has
that message inside of it. And it's crucial to them that that
message is reinforced in every single facet of
>> Yeah. I think I think Asmigle's misunderstanding a little
bit where some of this is coming from. I know I know like me,
Queen, and a couple other people like our our issue with that
was just that it was like this weird fake virtue signal about
how you shouldn't go to streamers for politics when you when
she just doesn't want to upset her audience, right? That was
the thing that annoyed us. I think there's a lot of people on
that same page. To be to be real, I think there's a ton of people
on that same page, right? You know, your audience comes from
Asold. You know, you get rated all the time by Asminold. You
know exactly why you don't want to comment on stuff. It's pretty
clear. >> Entertainment, media, and information. That's
what their goal is. And so once you understand that that's their
goal, you can understand how bad it is that they're doing this,
right? I mean, these are the it's about control, right? And so
they they're big E. Well, they're they're little D. I I think
so. It's more accurate. Uh the people are losers that do this.
They they don't these people like they can't win at the ballot
box and so they have to manufacture a false consensus on the
internet. That's
same thing as yesterday. Uh I understand where he's coming from.
I understand like his point of view. I understand what he's trying
to say. I don't think that was what was happening with Emiru,
especially not with the original tweet. I just don't think so.
I think I think people suspect Emirou has certain politics
and it's not that they uh
like here's here's actually I think people would have been even
more satisfied with that if she just said I think Asmin Gold
and Teone are harmful and are harmful to the political process.
I think that's more what they wanted. I don't think I think Asmin
Gold misunderstands that this is about politics. It's not about
politics. It's about people disliking him and thinking he's harmful.
Just remember, all right, because I've seen I've seen some DJers
try to say this now, okay? And I I do have to call it out. Just
remember what you guys did to Destiny when he was hanging out
with Dick Fuentes. All right. When he's buddy buddy with Nick
Fentes,
just remember you guys all pressured him, okay?
Is it really that crazy
to pressure her into disavowing like Asmin Gold's politics? the
the the avow of asmin sorry not the avow the um association with
asmin gold.
So she's hanging out with ice. Do you think this I'm saying I'm
arguing that I don't think this is about Ice anywhere near as
much as it's about her association with Asmin Gold.
I think that if Emiru had no association with Asmin Gold, there
would be no tweets about this.
And people say, well, she shouldn't be she shouldn't have to
make a statement on politics or she shouldn't have to make a
statement about him. And it's like, well, he's got some pretty
extreme politics. And I do think people would expect that out
of other people if it was like Fuentes who he who she was hanging
out with,
And do we see how much daylight is there between the two?
I don't think there's that much. I really don't. That's what
they have to do because the majority of Americans
have voted for mass deportations. This is what happened. They
support mass deportations.
And whenever you get into criminals being mass deported, that's
whenever you go into like the that 9010 area, right, where like
almost every single person agrees with this. So whenever you're
trying to manufacture a false consensus about, you know, oh actually,
no, that's not true. Americans actually want to have illegal
alien criminals in the country. It's not it's not even real.
So that the what they do instead is they find what they think
are easy targets like streamers, content creators, and other
types of people that are trying to do something on the internet
and they create a extremely toxic and hostile environment for
those. Okay, so this is just totally fake by the way. Okay, asold
is just lying.
He's totally lying. They didn't create this environment. Amiru
and her mod created this environment. Let's find the mic from
PA tweet. So, people are like trying to blame like Leftist for
making this happen. It wasn't leftist. It's literally her mod.
It's her mod. And apparently another mod she has I don't know
if it's this mod or another mod is like Asminold's head mod as
well. Like they're they mod both
right? What does Mike say here? It's weird because it was her
head mod asking that asked her about Ice while attacking Hassan.
Did she Oh, I I don't like this part. I don't know what this
part is. Did she set this up with her head mod to open an attack
on the left for coming after her when no one even asked? It's
not my fault. All your closest friends are Nazis or abusers/criminals.
Well, actually, that's I don't mind that last one, but
it it wasn't the left coming after her trying to get her to make
a statement. It was her mod getting her to make a state. Her
mod asked her.
Okay, her mod asked her. So this idea that like let this went
and made this a thing and they go around to chats and they bait
people into making statements. Shut the up. That's not what happened
here.
Like you guys go around and you make up all of this total this
obvious complete. But did the mod know how much that's not relevant?
No, I don't think I don't think the mod I don't think this part
is real. I I disagree with that part. But it's not like leftist
going to do it. This person is clearly not a leftist. This alley
Kitty person clearly doesn't like Hassan. She's like mocking
Emiru. What are your thoughts on Ice Hassan,
right? Hassanette is like a Hassan reference. It's like taking
a shot of Hassan. Is he not making He might be joking about some
other people somewhere else asking about it,
but she wasn't answering any of those questions. She was answering
her mod. Her mod asked the
We could go try to see if there's like thoughts if there's pieces
about ice in her chat in some other place.
But even then, she's answering a question from her mod here.
That's why she's answering it. Hold on. Angry bear nine Muffwin.
We're talking about one specific thing right now. This allegation
that left us go to chats and try to get you to comment on politics
because they don't want anywhere to be safe for you, right? When
that is clearly not what happened here. We agree that is clearly
not what happened here. Somebody suggesting that's what happened
here is lying. Obviously clearly lying.
who is dumb enough to suggest this with no evidence.
Okay,
I'm just going to call them a liar. You're just you're just making
this up.
It's an obvious lie.
Okay. And I don't like that.
Turns out I I dislike lying. Lying seems kind of bad. Lying seems
bad. Call me crazy. Lying bad.
>> Emer pick me for incel freaks. Honestly,
>> I Asminold has to listen. Asminold has to respect this.
Okay. Casey Tron's literally Randy Marsh in the South Park episode.
Hey. Hey, Baldi. I didn't hear no bell. I didn't hear no bell.
She's like back up. Got this kicked out of her. I didn't hear
no bell.
She's just ready to go. Okay. You got to respect it, man. You
got to respect it. >> Whatever am. >> He doesn't
want to say it. That's what I think that's what he was going
to say.
I got to respect this person's resilience. All right. >> Wearing
a cowboy hat because that's whenever she >> you She's wearing
a cowboy hat because she was playing Red Dead Redemption.
Oh, that's a cowboy game, by the way. Why are you so dumb?
This is crazy.
>> Started going like full Nazi, basically. >> Full
Nazi.
These people really are the worst.
They really are.
She's calling uh Imaru a Nazi. She's going full Nazi. Oh, wait.
No, she's calling Amaranath a Nazi. Oh, that totally makes more
sense.
I mean, Amaranth said some weird about the Holocaust. Okay, some
really weird. Amaranth for that like 10 minutes that Amaranth
was doing the weird right-wing stuff. She said some super weird.
Okay, let's just be totally real. She said some very weird things.
And yeah, she wasn't calling Emmy a Nazi here. Come on, man.
This is just
>> She started wearing the cowboy hat. It's like whenever
these Texas
girls in like these Austin, Texas streamer circles start wearing
cowboy hats, that's whenever you got to watch out. You know what's
really like I'm going to be honest.
This is one of the biggest minds to me that I've been having
to deal with for the last about 5 to 10 years of my life.
[laughter] You keep beating Caseyron and she comes back. Asmin
goes literally Dormamu. Okay.
Yeah, that's a Marvel reference. Okay. I've been playing a lot
of rivals.
As Casey Trron's got him stuck in a time loop. Okay.
Every single time Asmin Gold beats her,
suddenly she she respawns. Okay. She just respawns. She's like,
"You, no, I'm back. I'm back.
What's up, Asmin Gold? I'll [__] with your life again.
Talk to [__] again."
I am watching the previous generation of eirls and cool guys
on the internet like Casey Tron and Anthony Fantano
turn in
E girls Anthony Fantano to boring
middle-aged adults. I am watching eg girls turn into Karens.
Like this is the kind of stuff that like whenever you're whenever
you'd be at like uh you know Albertson's or something like that
or Publix or HB with your your mom in like 1998.
This is the kind of dialogue that you would hear them talking
about with like a celebrity with like the same level of like
the cadence, the demeanor, the vocabulary,
And we're watching this evolution
in real time. We are we're watching it in real time. Wow.
Wow.
I And it's happening to everybody else around me.
And I'm sitting here stressing myself out because it's like,
when's it gonna happen to me? >> Okay, let's be real.
Casey did a lot of drugs to get here. Okay, Casey did a lot of
drugs to get here at this point in life. >> When am I going
to go from being, you know, cuz like I feel like I've always
been a cool guy. I've always had a lot of friends. I, you know,
I like when is when am I going to turn into a loser?
They're about to start saying some really crazy
>> or maybe nothing at all. She's like basically like she
is she's like a pick me for like incel freaks. Like whenever
like a bunch of like ma
altight incel freaks start being like oh you're one of the good
girls.
>> What the are you talking about? >> I'll be honest.
I like on a factual real basis probably disagree with Casey Tron.
I don't I don't think Emir is like a pick me in any way. But
it is funny. >> I'm I'm laughing. I'm laughing at Asen
Gold's reaction. >> What the is she talking? This is insane.
She's actually crazy. Yes. >> You know, like, oh, you're
one of >> silence is violence. Oh my god.
>> The good one. >> How is she not? Because she doesn't
express political opinions.
You're confusing. you're you're you're
um
getting confounded by some like a very strong crossover and that's
with like performative online
you know manga type people wanting a
woman with the mind of a child
but it has nothing to do with the politics. She's not like a
pickme for the manga people. She's a pickme for people who want
a child's brain in a woman's body.
Okay, that's that's who she's a pickme for. It just happens that
a lot of the manga types are the people who want a woman with
the brain of a six-year-old child. Okay, so that that's where
you're confounding on something. Okay, it's not it is not the
fact that she's a pick me for politics. Okay, that's not true.
>> You're not like you know that she probably has like
weird incelss donating her hundreds of dollars every See, there's
one right there. There's one right there donating her like hundreds
of dollars every day. And they're >> what the
she's jealous. I will say again,
Casey Tron, this is what happened many years ago, 3,000 years
ago.
Casey Tron was the premier
top level streamer on Twitch. You can go back to 2012 and you'll
find videos of Caseyron
doing things. Hasn't been gold when Amber was getting bullied
by the internet.
Yeah. Yeah,
dude. Teone's got to be sitting there like, "Bro, you went like
1% this hard for me. You went like one. You didn't even go in
for me."
Entire internet's going after Tech. Asmin Gold's like, "I don't
mind Teeone." Internet goes at Emiru one time. He's like, "Twitter
needs to change their toos. This is unacceptable.
This is unacceptable." That are infinitely more degrading.
How many How many people told Techone to off himself? Asmin Gold
never once suggests changing the to. Okay.
>> One one thing where Emirou I'm surprised Emiru even
wants to continue living and Azoul's LIKE CHANGE THE TO NOW everything
else than anything that any of the modern streamers are doing
right now that are very popular like Emer
and you know what happened to Caseyron my ex-girlfriend started
streaming
and I got to tell you guys
there is a number of reasons why I dated her and there are that
many equal reasons why everybody stopped watching Caseyron
and watched my ex-girlfriend instead.
He just imply he only dated his ex-girlfriend for her and that's
why everyone watched that girl instead of Is that is that what
he's implying right now? [laughter]
Okay. All right. Fair enough. >> And seems kind of weird.
I thought he was like really into that relationship and like
that person. He has been permanently mad about that
for over 10
>> Who is his ex? Pink Sparkles. Somebody named Pink Sparkles
is his ex.
>> 10 years. Sad.
It's really sad. Very sad. See, people don't understand like
this is somebody you are a failed egirl.
You tried to be an egirl and you lost in the free market of eirls.
Denim's post. What's this? The Denim's post alleged Emiru Asminold
DMs admits Ice feud. >> Yeah, there's a huge AI.
>> There's a huge AIL. [laughter] >> You know what
I find is really funny about this? You know what I could do?
I could post Denim's real DMs in Destiny's chat asking to have
with
>> What?
No way.
>> You're sitting in here writing fanfiction. Don't make
me tell the
Don't do that.
>> He's so pressed right now. I've I've literally never
seen Dude, people come to Asenold and they're like, "You your
mom and your dad is happy that you're that he's dead now that
he doesn't have to live with you." And Asen Gold's like, "Water
off a duck's back, [__] I don't feel you're a piece
of for saying that, but I don't feel anything from it." And now
people Denim is like, "Here's an obviously photoshopped image
that's a famous meme. A literal famous meme. What's going on
with the economy? Don't worry, kitten." And he's like,
"You you [__] Destiny, you stupid.
You want me to talk about how you Destiny, you stupid." He just
loses it. It's actually I didn't believe that he was dating Emmy
until he started responding to some of this stuff. And now I'm
like, Jesus, there's like a lot
there's a lot of Yeah,
he's he's showing exactly
Listen, if this were like a a Zelda game, okay, there's like
a big glaring like red flashing button on the boss right now.
And I don't, you know, I don't want to say anything cuz I don't
think I think this thing for me is trying to go at somebody you
don't like like Asmin Gold by going through somebody else that
they care about is really gross to me. I don't actually like
that. Okay. I think people are doing that. I think there's a
tangible way to defend that if it's about politics and about
Asold's political opinions. But I think if you just want to make
him upset as a person, right, I think you should go after him.
I don't think you should go after Emiru. Now, you could say I
think she should have to answer some political questions because
of the association that I'm I'm more open to, especially because
it's been a professional association for so long, right? But
I don't I don't like that. But he is absolutely like flagging
that this is the thing that upsets him,
which I think, you know, it sucks because he's probably just
being human and feeling that emotion like he wants to defend
Emiru right now. But he is absolutely he's throwing up massive
flags to everybody that this is the that actually upsets him.
Okay.
He's flagged up for PvP. I don't think she's flagged up for PvP.
But I'm just I'm saying that he's he's giving this away in a
way that he really shouldn't be right now in my >> Don't
you put me in a position where I got to tell the truth. What
a stupid
Oh my god. She's sitting in Destiny's chat begging for him to
her and then she's sitting around here. I think I think he means
Discord messages like Discord DMs. >> Photoshop and DMs
to farm hate on
Crazy Photoshop there. Pretty sure that could just be MS Paint.
Pretty sure that's like a famous meme. Everybody knows exactly
what's going on there. >> There's one word for that, >> you
know.
>> Hose mad.
>> Sad. Really?
>> It's just sad.
I've literally seen him I've never seen him this pressed in my
entire time of watching Asmin Gold. Never seen him this pressed
about anything. >> His like really misogynistic
insult like men. They like a woman that doesn't have any opinions.
>> They like [clears throat] a woman doesn't have any opinions.
Oh yeah. They like women. Yeah. Right. Of course they like Yeah.
Um Okay.
>> You know they're like [laughter] Oh >> Dude, I
didn't know Aspen Gold had emotions. I didn't think they were
there. I've never seen it. I've never seen this before. >> Somebody
that I can mold to have all of the same right-wing manga opinions
that I have. And then I think that she also >> I love how
like she's just writing like she's just making all of this up.
She's totally making everything about this up. Like it's just
it's you're just you're just you're just making up. It's just
it's basically like this massive fanfiction that she's inventing.
Oh my god, this is so sad.
>> I think that she also plays into how a lot of incelss
will fetishize
Asian women as being more docile.
>> Her whole platform is just like appealing to like the
worst men. >> Her whole platform is appealing to the worst
men. Meanwhile, she's raiding food, wearing a cowboy hat, and
she's going to play Red Dead Redemption.
Take your meds.
Take your meds, Casey. >> So embarrassing.
This is insanely
embarrassing.
I don't know why some of these other girl streamers even like
associate with her. It's like, >> isn't it crazy how like,
do you remember what I was telling you before about how women
like to do PvP, but the difference between female PvP and male
PvP is that the female PvP, they try to pretend like they're
not flagged. So, what she's trying to do is she's trying to like
create a narrative that other people should isolate and alienate
Emiru because of all these lies that you've just made up about
her. This is the absolute worst of this is like whenever people
talk about toxic masculinity, this this is toxic feminine behavior.
It absolutely is. And I want you guys to see it. This is like
>> like a textbook example. You open up the dictionary,
this clip is in the dictionary.
There it is. You toxic femininity.
Uh I think she just hates people associated with you. Think she
hates you. Hates people associated with you. you you know somebody
who is on I guess that side of the fence kind of tried to ruin
her life. She's you know getting her get back I think.
>> See it right here.
>> Seems pretty outcast. That's right. >> Like you're
just bringing over like her weird incel viewers into your You
know what I mean? >> Weird incel viewers.
Oh my god.
That's your audience. That's your guys. Asmin go. That's who
she's talking about. That's who she's talking about right there.
>> Let's not forget that she, you know, had a bunch of
money donated to a women's charity that she had uh, you know,
like she donated money herself to the Alvea sanctuary. Like,
let's not talk about that at all. Let's just say that all of
her viewers are weird incelss.
>> He's just again, he's flashing up that flag. I wish
he wouldn't do this. >> Jesus Christ. Isn't this weird?
Uh, >> and then in my >> No, no, no, no, no. I'm
fine. This could all be real. I don't think like you have to
go after Emiru here. I don't think that's a requirement. I don't
think that's like something you should be doing. I just I'm sitting
here and I'm like, dude, I He's He's like making this a thing
that he he wouldn't have to. He doesn't have to make this a thing,
man. But he's making it a thing. >> My opinion, it's like
she's not entertaining whatsoever. >> Oh, here we go. Here
we go. Why are they watching? Sometimes there might be cases
where just like not saying anything could be better. This might
be one of those cases. Okay. >> Know when they should be
watching me. Of
>> she's like I would literally rather watch paint dry.
Like her only pull is really just like being like the egirl to
a bunch of weird basement dwelling
>> Oh, she got her eyes open now whenever she's talking
about appearance. Oh. Oh. Now, [laughter] I would just say probably
all you got to do is look at the follows of the people who who
talk in emir's chat. I'm guessing you throw a dart, you find
some combination of like totally DG e- girls who stream in bikinis,
of YouTubers, and then as golden techone. I'm guessing that's
like a 50% hit rate on all three of those being present in someone's
follows. Okay, >> now she's locked in. Oh, wait a minute.
>> Be real. >> Oh, I'm awake now. I'm ready. Oh my
god. >> Like, I'm sorry. And like I said, this is just
my opinion.
>> it's just it's just her opinion, but >> it's just
my opinion. I'm just going to participate in complete reputation
destruction, compounding lies, and then advocate for other people
not to communicate with you or ostracize you because of the compounding
lies that I just invented in my own mind. >> I don't think
Was this clip really blowing up? Maybe this clip was blowing
up, actually. >> She sucks. And I mean like I don't know.
>> I just I don't Yeah, I think
how would I say the reputation destruction it's like she has
a bad you know a bad
opinion of Emiru. She has clearly is a bad opinion. I don't know
if her throwing her bad opinion or her her opinion that is very
negative of Emirou into the circle. I don't know if that's necessarily
her doing reputation >> I think that this was a long time
coming. I think the other thing that was just like okay is how
she didn't say anything whenever it came to techone and
>> You know,
>> I think that makes a lot of sense because, you know,
as somebody who was a victim on public, you know, like publicly
in front of everybody uh at Twitch sexual >> Oh,
[laughter] >> well, I'm sure it's because she actually
supports it.
>> Yeah, I think that makes a lot of sense.
Of course.
Duh. I don't know that you do. You pull that flag for her maybe.
Do you do you pull that shield out? >> This the KIND
>> NEVER TALK NEVER TALK ABOUT EMIRU. SHE was assaulted.
Never talk about Emmy. >> The [__] these people
say. >> I don't know. I don't know. >> Didn't say
anything like in support of Pinky Chu or like you know um like
yeah like I don't associate with like it's just weird. >> It's
just um weird and very >> I don't know what happened here.
We've been known. We've been known. >> We've been new on
this stream.
>> We know that this this girl is weird.
>> Jesus, guys. Like, I just really
>> like this is just it could she get banned for defamation?
I mean, I don't know why like >> Yeah. I just I think having
like a negative opinion of somebody and talking about like the
things they do or don't do and how it forms your opinion. I don't
know if you could call that reputation destruction. And if you
can call that reputation destruction, then certainly Tecton and
Aszmold would be equally guilty as far as like misgiv, right?
Like certainly
I think Casey Tron is like I used to be very very pro-smoking
weed and I was like, "Oh, it's not going to do anything wrong
to you. Oh, you're going to be fine. Don't worry about it." But
like after I've watched her talk about some [__]
I think to myself like, man, maybe smoking weed isn't that bad
or actually is that bad. Like maybe it can you up. Like that's
it. And and you have all these people going and talking [__]
like this and it's just sad to see. We're doing a speedrun for
ad hominemum attacks today.
>> Yeah. It's just it's really just such a it's such a
nasty thing to say about a person. It really is. and uh just
to go out and lie and just make up constantly and uh it's really
embarrassing
and uh don't blame the weed. How many prescriptions is she on?
I don't know. But uh yeah, it's just really like the amount of
harassment like this that happens especially from people like
her is just disgraceful. Absolutely disgraceful. People should
be ashamed of themselves. They really should. >> But uh
that'll never happen.
>> That'll never happen at all. So yeah, and uh that's
it.
And uh what why is making me do this? I don't know, man. But
uh yeah, no, I I just the people that do this are just such a
dude, >> dude. Can he can he get angry enough at leftwingers
doing this that he'll become a Zionist?
I think it's possible. I think it's possible we will see Asminold
kissing the wall within 6 months. Okay, it's not impossible.
All right, I do believe within six months we could see Asmin
Gold kissing the wall. All right. I think I think so.
Listen, he's he's already changing a lot because of Emiru. I
do believe maybe Emiru is is Emir Israel's greatest scop to turn
the proto groper biggest influencer on multiple platforms right-wing
influencer to turn him pro-Israel. Was she a long-term plant
genetically engineered to be the perfect
right-wing child bride? Okay.
and deployed at just the right time when Israel would need her
most. >> They're just awful, awful, awful people. They're
terrible. [snorts] And so that's it. He's been posting clips
of people uh attacking. What's going on? I haven't seen that.
If I see any of these other ones, but uh I haven't seen what
other people are saying or anything like that. And uh what I
think is funny is that
>> I think that it's very difficult to have any tether
to someone with the degree of
>> Yeah. political influence like the cultural and political
influence of Asmin Gold has become so enormous and so
>> thank you thank you keep watching keep >> synonymous
with the dismantling of good faith discourse in online spaces
that it's very difficult to [laughter] not
>> wait what do you mean it's true
that you're synonymous with the dismantling of good faith discourse
in public spaces
with the dismantling of good faith discourse in online spaces
that it's very difficult to not >> true it's true >> have
that friendship color what you go on to omit >> yeah I'm
not sure what he means by that >> you know like I think
the reason why people don't care about whether or not someone
like Tyler one or like Clint Stevens or you know
>> squeaks you know I think the reason why people probably
might not like constantly pry press or attempt to get positions
out of them is because their affiliations don't suggest
a sort of permissive attitude towards certain ideologies. How
is Asold going to handle this? Cuz I think this guy's fairly
in with a lot of those Austin streamers, right?
And I do think that Wake is Wake doesn't really mince words here.
He is kinder about it, but he doesn't really mince words in that
he basically says, "I understand exactly why people would do
this with Emmy. I'm not going to say she has to respond, but
she has to understand why people are concerned or why people
would think this, right?"
And I think it's it's very funny because yeah, the way he handles
this is
meant to not immediately put Asmin Gold off. So, he's gonna listen
to it, but it will
it's not really that far away from something like what Denims
is saying or what Mike's saying. Okay. It's not that far away.
>> I disagree. I think it's because those people already
made their values known.
I think that's the reason why. >> What? I don't know who
Tyler one voted for. I don't know who Squeaks voted for. I don't
know who those people voted for. How the [__] How
would I know that? Where have they made those opinions known?
What? like they've already talked about this and made comments
about it themselves.
Like all those people talk about it like they don't go and say
it regularly, but they do make off-handed comments. Maybe not
Tyler one. >> And so it's a difficult thing to have a public
friendship with someone who is now become synonymous with like
alt-right vitriol
>> and like to then not take a stance is probably where
people are taking that issue. Right. >> I think there's
a degree like I I I'll approach this in good faith. I've known
Wake for a long time and so like I I like the guy. I actually
do. I think that what he's saying is kind of true that like whenever
you're in close proximity to a person, we chat holy world word
salad. That wasn't a word salad. Wake's one of those guys. There's
some guys like this who do probably like I I have no doubt that
Wake is not the fastest on his feet mentally or something, okay?
like he just seems like a dude bro a lot of the time. But there
are guys like this who might not necessarily be able to go and
like verbally spar and totally like win conversations. But they're
they're deep thinkers in that they will spend a lot of time thinking
about things and how they're going to say things. And they will
say things that are well thought out, right? You don't have to
be like 150 IQ to say things that are intelligent
that's like really wellknown and that person has a lot of uh
you know opinions, right? It's like for example, this happens
with a too me. I think that overall you will have AoE damage
with other people. You definitely will. And that's actually one
of the big reasons why I stepped away from interacting with a
lot of other people. It's because I know that I have a very big
platform. I know a lot of people, you know, like
like for most people the worst day of their life is my Tuesday
in terms of online discourse and hate and stuff like that. You
say you're an honest assault, right? And it's like say that's
like Trump saying, "Oh, if people dealt with like the hate I
get for one day that they they wouldn't be able to handle." It's
like, "Yeah, but you signed up for that. You went in with open
eyes. You signed up for that directly. You don't really get to
complain about that after the fact." Okay. Like, come on, man.
What are you trying to say? Why would you get to complain about
that? You literally signed up for it. Come on, >> Well,
I think that a lot of people on the internet think that, right?
Like, whether that's true or not is kind of irrelevant. What
I think he's saying is that if you have a person, Destiny says
that too. It's Yeah. It's like if you are intentionally as inflammatory
as possible, you intentionally try to drive hatred towards yourself
as a means of growing your platform, you can do that. But then,
you know, Teone, Destiny, Asmin Gold, uh, Trump, a lot of these
people, it's like, I don't want to hear about you getting hate
after. Oh, I get more hate than anybody could understand. It's
like, yeah, you explicitly went that way. You engineered your
whole career that way.
Like, you you don't get to complain about it after the fact.
That's like the strategy you chose. You chose that.
out there that has a really big reputation and that person goes
out and you know like is interacting with somebody else that's
going to be there's like an an AOE effect of that like we have
like every hot button issue is on the stream. So it makes sense
that somebody that doesn't want to get involved with that wouldn't
want to be involved with that. There's nothing really wrong with
that at all. >> Okay, but that's not actually materially
answering his question or coming close to answering it. He says
you are synonymous with the online like alt-right. He's he's
making the point, right, that you are not that dissimilar from
Nick Fuentes.
And so people who professionally associate with you, especially
people who are close friends of yours, they may have to make
decisions when they're like a wholesome streamer, they may have
to make a decision on whether or not they're going to be associated
with you at all. They might have to be pre they might be pressured
by virtue of the kind of content they do, right?
Like you could say, "Oh, well that that's unfair or that shouldn't
be that way." But it's not totally unreasonable depending on
what their vertical is. I think Emy's fine because I think Emmy
has a lot of Asmin viewers who aren't going to ask her to separate,
right? For a lot of other people, I actually think her statement
probably hurts her more than anything
to be honest with you. I think her statement doesn't work out
well for her. But it's he didn't actually answer the question.
He's like, "Oh, well, I understand why people wouldn't want to
be associated with me." Okay, but that's not what Wake is saying.
Wake is saying it's not wrong to expect people to make a statement
on their association with you or their thoughts on your politics
when that association paints them very negatively. That's a very
negative association. You are synonymous with it. People may
have to intentionally intentfully disavow or disassociate with
you. And it's not and he's saying explicitly it's not wrong for
other people
to ask that to ask for that.
>> So I got no problem with that. I don't think I'm saying
anything wrong or bad. people might want to disagree with it.
And that's
definitely a uh there's like a a val
Oh, he's cutting out. Okay. You good? I'm trying to get at. And
uh that's why I'm always saying you surround yourself with like-minded
people. No, you can't. you. The thing is that even people that
are like-minded are still not like I don't think people recognize
I don't think people recognize the amount of
discourse and people talking about
like I I I'm not listen I'm not a big guy for oh I'm so important
I'm the most important biggest guy out there or anything like
that >> but uh f wait a And wait, what? And I'm doing great.
And I don't know what the hell that was. So, uh, what was I saying
before? I forgot. Oh, yeah. Uh, so is it right or wrong to expect
people to to want a statement from Emiru? Either on the politics
you're associated with or a disavow of you as a as a political
>> Destiny comment about denims to defend Emer. Oh god.
Destiny,
an unlikely ally.
>> This cringe weird obsession. Why are we forcing What
is with this cringe weird obsession? Why are we forcing streamers
to give their opinions on sociopolitical topics? I think that
there's like there is a legitimate argument that if you're a
larger influencer, you should probably know something going on
about the um the state of your country. It's kind of >> but
the reality is what's going on is Emaru is on the side of Ethan
or whatever or has said like positiveish things about the lawsuit
stuff. So now denims and all these fake bimbo losers that don't
actually give a about anything use this as a vector to attack
emo just so cringe and boring. Oh my
Wow. So literally not literally not a defense of Emiru at all.
Just like uh muddying the waters so you could attack
>> because like what happens if Emu comes out and like
oh actually guys like you're right for like it's not like they're
like oh good job. We're happy you did it. know
>> I I assume from the very beginning it was nice every
everybody did >> you destiny he's right >> some other
angle >> and there's also like a way like if you think
it's really important to get people to >> if somebody is
not your enemy >> and you want to get them on board with
>> the worst thing to do is to treat them like an enemy
>> thing you want them to say right >> yeah that
I guess maybe I'm the only person who interpreted this is like
they just don't like Asminold they don't like people who are
going to, you know, buoy Asmin Gold's reputation.
I think you could say that's wrong. Feels like a feels like a
little weird
when Denims calls me a Destiny Orbiter. Just remember it really
sucks that we didn't wait. Are you actually serious? No. On good
terms with who? Atlas. I wanted to Atlas and you.
So, this is the person who's making up fake DMs. You know what?
I don't know what this addresses at all. I The fake DMs were
a meme.
He's so pressed about this.
He's so insanely pressed about it. It's so funny, man.
Okay. Okay. >> But I've always said, every accusation is
a confession.
Oh, I remember this.
I do.
>> Wow.
It's fine. >> Off camera. Yeah. This is really embarrassing
for me. Projecting. Yep. projecting like crazy. Projecting insanity.
Destiny had to wait. What's this here? Destiny had to kick her
out of his house. What the [__] is this? Cuz Denim's
snuck into his house and like a dude in his bed, right? >> Head
and the guy. And I realized that Denims and the guy had just
spent the last two days in my apartment with my computer on like
all my I'm like, what the um this was incredibly weird. I just
I can't be the only one who thinks like Willie Mack and Asminold
could plausibly be cousins, right? I can't be I can't be the
only one.
Like, it seems pretty obvious. Yeah. >> To me. I don't
know why she thought I would have been okay with that. It was
so dramatic. I sat them both down. I was like, "Listen, okay,
this is all too much. Too dramatic, too. Like, I don't want anything
to do with either of you guys. This is like crazy. This has gotten
like way too wacky." Um, they both acknowledged that they had
both been like unhinged and crazy and they understood and blah
blah blah. And then after that, like we like all kind of went
our separate ways. Now, I did record that conversation because
the big fear I had and this happened two days later. Denims goes
online with her new guy and she's like, "Stephen kicked me out
because I wouldn't." >> And that's pretty much what she's
claiming now. So, when Destiny offered me the recording, I >> Oh
my god. Destiny kicked me out because I wouldn't. This is This
You know what this is like? Th this was I thought this was Bro,
this is so pathetic. I can't believe it. Oh my god. The really
funny thing here though
is like maybe she just spoke poorly cuz she almost got it. Destiny
was mad cuz you another dude.
That's he wanted you to be like obsessed with him but you just
another guy like in his house. That's why he was mad,
right? It wasn't that you wouldn't him. It was that you another
dude instead of him in his bed. That was what he was mad about.
Which, you know, I mean, it's fair to be mad about that, I suppose.
I'm just it it's not like he wasn't mad about it. He he was mad
about it. It's not like she was super far off there.
Um I think maybe if I I'd have to see how what she implied a
couple days later where apparently she implies that like it was
some kind of pressure thing for me or you can't stay with me.
I I don't think that's the case, but
>> yeah, obviously >> weird. And not only that, but
you couldn't even lie about it correctly. You told three different
lies to different people. You told Molina, "Ew, I would never."
[snorts] And I got to do >> that. I never said that. >> You
did. I I looked at the text. You >> OMFG. No.
>> Okay. OMFG. No. So, I come home and you're both still
here. >> I never said that. Meanwhile,
Meanwhile, guys, I never said that.
What?
Dude, asold, by the way, this is all because Denim tweeted this
stupid set of DMs, this like stupid meme. Asold's gone and pulled
up apparently these uh illegally recorded conversations from
Destiny. Dude, it's it's so weird being able to see through the
matrix of like the way Destiny operates. You rewatch this stuff
and you can like see exactly what's going through his mind as
he does this stuff. It's just it's very
it's very funny. You can see exactly why he's upset. >> Why
would you why would you put me in this weird spot where I had
to come home and see an incredibly creepy guy that is such a
weird position in my community that's been trying to get me to
stop talking to my ex-girlfriend because he's trying so hard
to her is now somebody else in my bed dragging his hairy balls
across my blankets. [laughter] Okay. Oh my god. And so we leave
for an hour. He's like, "Holy [__] that's weird."
So, we leave for an hour and come back and he and you're both
still there. Oh god. >> I don't know if he's like I need
to get like a few more logs or pictures off of Destiny's computer.
>> Holy sh I don't think I've ever What the is going on
that hard where I've tried to like my entire life? I don't think
I've ever been like so burned on something before. Holy [__]
>> Destiny kicks her out of the house and before she goes
she says, "I thought it was okay because I thought this weirdo
guy changed for the better." Completely missing the point. It's
not even that there. Yeah, it's a random person in your house.
>> I'm like, am I a like I thought I was a pretty good
judge of characters, so now I'm like, am I really >> Here's
the thing. It's It's more the having It's not the random person.
You say somebody can sit at your place. Let me put it this way.
If Denim's brought another hot streamer girl over
and they [__] the Destiny's bed, do you think Destiny's
upset?
Right. I We can all tell what the what the problem is.
I it's very clear to me what the problem is. Okay. Anyway, super
pressed. Super pressed on that. >> Really kind of crazy.
So many in this world. That's exactly right. And uh time for
a psych word. Yeah. This is what these people do, man. Is that
they go out like they are like this is why like there's no thesis
to what he's trying to say here. He's not building to like a
bigger point. He's literally going look how bad Denims is. Denims
did a meme. Well, look how bad Denims is. Denim sucks, man. Denim
sucks. Denim sucks. Denim sucks. It's like, wait, what was your
point though that like
I don't know what was your point with
Well, his point was apparently uh doing fake DMs or something.
She was doing fake DMs. That's obviously not true. It's obviously
a lie,
right? I I feel like you have to say something about what these
people are doing. you have to say something about it because
it's just so just blatantly dishonest, aggressive, and just it's
just really at the end of the day, it's just behavior. So, yeah,
can't trust that. Which, by the way, it might be that Denims
is like annoyed that Amiru had any comments on her court case,
right? On her um her case with Ethan Klein. She might have been
annoyed that Amiru commented on it in a way that put her thumb
on the scale for Asmin Gold or for Asmin Gold. I have some gold's
friends. Sorry. Right. She might have been annoyed about that.
It doesn't mean she's like obsessed. She's just like, "Oh, this
is funny. You
not super deep. It's not like an obsession. It's literally she's
doing a couple tweets, man. Uh [clears throat] doing negative
tweets about other people is being obsessed
reading,
[laughter]
you know, hundreds of Discord pages, pages of Discord logs about
somebody else's Discord. Okay. like a 500 sorry 400 viewer streamers
discord not obsessed tweeting two times about about uh Emiru
super obsessed obviously >> anyone who lies so blatantly
I mean yeah that's and fundamentally I think this is one of the
things that you guys need to understand about these people is
that all they do is lie
they're not trying to engage anything in good faith they're not
trying to have a conversation they're not trying to you know
express a viewpoint they're just trying to make up a bunch of
bull and attack anybody who >> we just watched wake express
a viewpoint basically explain why people should want okay asking
this question he didn't engage with it he didn't engage with
the >> who doesn't agree with them totally bad faith yeah
it's completely bad faith and
>> sure but is anybody aware of her talking about it at
length I'm saying that I think the thing Destiny saw was the
tweets right that not what he saw you think he's aware of how
much she talked about it on her stream
saying twoth3 of the farright party Japan. Let me see if I can
find this in a minute. Sh from Assan. Well, I think that everybody
everybody in the online leftist space generally I think prescribes
to this like massive collective co
>> subscribes ascribes of dissonance >> where they
all just repeat the same lies and the same vocabulary
infinitely over and over and over in order to effectively signal
that they are part of the end group. And I think it's actually
what makes them very effective because too many people don't
know how to deal with it. They
there's got to be a thing like it would be fun just to show all
these political all these political streamers describing the
other group's tactics directly and it's just their tactics directly.
Like there are people who do this on the left. Sure. Tons of
people who do this on the right all the [__] time,
right? Like everybody does this and you could say that, oh the
other side does this, but everybody everybody's everyone's doing
exactly what he's describing. Oh, there'll be these little like
micro lies you could tell that are funny and signal you're a
part of the group. JD Vance couch play the Denim's response.
Oh, wait. Denim's responded. Oh, is this Denim's responding to
that? >> The problem is this is I think the worst performance
I've seen from Asma Gold yet. And this is how I know that he's
actually very offended on behalf. Normally by now he's cracked
a couple jokes. He's laughed a little bit. He's done some character
smears by now. But he's actually in so so invested that for the
first time in I don't even know how long. Like he's actually
mad about it. So I can only imagine oh what I would give to be
a fly on the wall. >> Bro, if I were Asmin Gold, by the
way, this is the one thing Denims is good at is she is like uh
pardon my language here, okay? Cuz I know I got some lefties
in the audience, but she is a smug.
I would I would lose my [__] so badly if Denim's
got one over on me and then was like smug about it on stream.
This is the one thing she's actually very good at is she does
does this little smile at the camera. I'm like you f I I'll be
honest. I think she's like winning. I'm like I'm laughing. I'm
laughing from the sidelines right now. And I can watch her like
do these face at the camera and I'm like
I just want to punch something.
[__] What this stupid [__]
The incel rises up just a little bit. Okay. I'm like
>> it's like she she's just got like the voice. She got
like the little smiles.
It's just it's like that exact thing going on. I understand how
it pisses everybody off. Okay. I don't know about the political
analysis. I don't know about anything else, but when she just
wants to be like smug about something and make people like enraged,
very >> That's how I know that he's actually very offended
on behalf of Emiru.
>> Normally by now he's cracked a couple jokes. He's laughed
a little bit. He's done some character smears by now. But he's
actually insu so invested that for the first time in I don't
even know how long. Like he's actually mad about it. So I can
only imagine, oh what I would give to be a fly on the wall, a
roach on the wall for that conversation. Oh, I wish I could have
been there. Damn it. But anyways, um he is genuinely so mad.
He is genuinely so mad right now cuz again, normally at this
point he would have made a bunch of jokes. He would have I will
say if I were Emiru, I'd feel a little gunshy here going right
back to the well again. Okay, cuz with Ethan Klein, I think she
pissed Ethan Klein off so much that Ethan Klein like broke all
of his principles to go after her. And realistically, how much
money you got that you would risk Asminold doing the same thing
to just like him if he just wants to like sue you? If he just
wants to throw a slapsuit at you, I I respect it. I hope not.
>> Smeared my character. He would have smeared it by saying
like, "Well, who even cares what this person?" Everybody knows
that Dan
shouldn't be streaming. But he's actually really mad. So, he's
taking he's doing something he never he's he never does this.
Taking the moral high ground and saying this is just about basic
dignity and and we should be nice to each other and and just
because somebody doesn't want to speak on something, they shouldn't
have to speak on it. >> Like the and the funny thing about
this is that this is friendly fire.
Listen, Emmy has a lot of libtarted opinions. She does like it.
It's pretty obvious. But just because she doesn't want to talk
about it on stream, they treat her as if she's a Nazi,
>> you know. Actually, she's a great person on the inside.
She just never shares it or does anything.
It's giving um
what's the meme? It's like reading
mine cough on the >> I'm sure I'm sure she does some good
things. I come on guys. >> Train and shaking my head the
entire time. So >> sound like she gave money to that animal
sanctuary. Okay, >> everybody knows I'm against it. >> You
know, some good things. >> Okay, what do you want me to
do with that information? She's actually she actually has a lot
of leftist opinions but she doesn't share them. Isn't that worse
that she chooses to be silent on issues that she has the right
opinion on so that she can make money? What?
But the one thing that I don't think it could be considered worse
and was the original criticism should have been the original
criticism for most of these people. Either groups of these people
have the right to is to take streamers and people that don't
want to be involved in this and then lie, bully, and malign them
into having a viewpoint and then attack them whenever they take
a step in the wrong direction.
>> So, um, here's the thing. Uh, people would have defended
her right to say, "I don't know enough." So, I don't want to
speak on this issue. But, >> uh, here's the problem is
they're also lying about like her response. She just said she
didn't want to comment on it because she didn't know enough.
No, that's not all she said. No, that's not all she said. If
that was all she said, she gets way less hate here.
I don't know. People are out to lunch on this. Um, actually,
if she just said, "I don't want to comment on it cuz I don't
I don't know enough." Or if she just said, "I don't comment on
politics." I don't know enough. She could have gotten a little
heat for that. I don't comment on politics on my stream.
Easy. So easy.
Okay, that's all she got to do. That's all she had to do. >> But
that's not what she said. And it doesn't matter how much you
cope and see about it. It doesn't change what she said. And what
she said was, "I don't even know why you guys care. I'm not going
to take a stance on it. I'm not going to tell you guys what my
stance is on it. You guys need to go outside." So she insulted
her audience, insulted anyone who was watching her, accused them
of only wanting to know what her opinion was so that they can
have an opinion and then said, "Well, I'm not going to have a
stance. I'm apolitical." Which is different than I don't want
to speak on this cuz I don't know that I'm comfortable enough
to speak on it. Those are different sentences. Those are different.
Doesn't matter how much you try and pretend like those are the
same sentence. They're different.
Ah, I hate I hate it. I hate having to agree with a smug person.
Okay. But I do agree.